our country is becoming something less
desired to fight and risk your life for
with the way it's the direction is
trending it's like there was a time
where where people would would die for
their country certainly and people would
go to war and go to battle and people do
anything for their country but when you
look at what we're dealing with today in
today's climate with with just the state
of the country it doesn't look like
something that everyone's just jumping
forward to to put everything on the line
for I'm more focused I feel that way
about my community and my family and my
friends I'm I'm like gung-ho about
protecting that infrastructure of
community and and in churches and and
people that are that are in my everyday
life you know I just I think it would be
hard to get
people to to risk their lives for this
state of this country homelessness
everything that's going on it's a shame
and what you're doing serves the
military because it protects and
stabilizes the local communities so that
they don't have to worry about coming in
to defend it you're there you're going
to protect it right but we we gotta
start thinking about protecting the
local communities I think